tom put all my records into this
rectangle
she don't care about no fancy trans
she's just a mom from old south bend
get home safe boys and thank you for
protecting our freedom
let's play it again
so music should we turn some music that
sounds good
do you guys remember my old assistant
hunter
he is an excellent songwriter we didn't
hear this
[Music]
you made everything
[Music]
number one could you please sing the
opening to i want it that way really
okay
you are
my fire
number two keep it going the one
desire
number three believe
when i
say number four i
wanted that away
tell me why ain't nothing but a
heartache
say
[Applause]
oh chills literal chills it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
god i forgot about that part
oh my god something's happening
nine million nine hundred eighty-six
thousand minutes
we actually sat down and did the math
nine million nine hundred eighty-six 000
minutes
that's how many minutes that you've
worked here
in costumes and impressions in meetings
in cups of coffee for birthdays more
meat exams email forwards you made us
read
9 million 986 000 minutes
that's like watching die hard 80 000
times
you hit me with your car you help me get
off drugs i watch you when you sleep i
forgive you for kissing me
[Music]
measure your life
[Music]
[Music]
yeah okay
well this is gonna hurt like a mother
you sneak out of here do not be
suspicious
don't be suspicious don't be suspicious
oh
of weird
sitting silently in a private karaoke
room not singing yeah but we're on a
mission so you know got to stay focused
so i wake in the morning and i step
[Applause]
what's going on
okay too fast everyone we need to pump
at a pace of 100 beats per minute oh
okay that's uh hard to keep track how
many is that per hour how's that gonna
help you i will divide and then count to
it right okay well a good trick is to
pump to the tune of staying alive by the
bee gees do you know that song yes yes i
do i love that song
first i was afraid i was petrified no
it's
staying alive
you were in the parking lot earlier
that's how i know you
ah
ah staying alive staying alive
stay
since i was born when it's all right
it's okay you can't look
yeah okay you didn't maintain 100 beats
per minute and the ambulance didn't
arrive because nobody called 9-1-1 so
you lost him okay
[Applause]
and uh you shouldn't torture whales uh
there was a period of time where you i'm
sorry about cece
thanks lemon
want to get drunk
no there's too many phones in here
you should have gone for it you know you
made the same choice that cece and i did
you chose your career over floyd
i've
[Music]
i miss that midnight train
[Music]
and i was misinformed about
the time misinformed about the time
didn't need to get
[Music]
hello i'm trying to take a nap
checking out the hotties with their sexy
body still drinking boucle champagne we
all got maseratis
[Music]
our future adds up to this the best
things
[Music]
so what are you waiting five girls
every song i download has to pass a
series of rigorous tests to answer one
simple question
is it a banger how many beats per minute
how many drops how dope are the drops
were any acoustic instruments used if so
it is not a banger i once accidentally
downloaded the lumineer song
i had to throw away my whole computer
just being safe
you